foreign
[Music]
get your hands behind your back get them
behind your back
yes
give me your other hand
17th Street Highway 200 at a motorcycle
Queen for me I am 10 15 on it secret
option yeah put your knees up to your
chest confirming your fingers
I'm gonna get my bike up fled and um I
was able to stop them in traffic please
all the way up
sorry about that man what are you
playing dude I didn't have my plate on
and I freaked out
hit me hit on with that bike
oh
21 hours I just need a unit I got nobody
took care of this guy
[Music]
nothing up what are you playing I had my
milk plate on I just
I don't know
you see me trying to pull you over yeah
I heard my siren right
while it goes it goes you get a license
why are you playing
what is wrong with you
I went around me I tried to pull you
over I really don't understand if you
wanna
you're going to jail today for fleeing
and looting yeah for real what's up with
the bike there's no tag on it
I have I have a tag I have everything
I was literally going to Lakeland I
didn't want to pay the toll so I took
the tag off wow he didn't want to pay
the toll seemed Super Saga right now yes
you are is this vehicle ready true to
you yes sir
he started fleeing from me back here
started cutting between traffic well he
had to slow down with all the traffic I
was able to tip up here pull in front
and cut them off after I cut him off he
tried to go around he all jumped out of
my car and he freaking revved it and hit
me and everybody dropped it yeah well I